we've been talking about this a little
bit lately uh this is
we're gonna do three more weeks of the
night tonight show and then sort of wrap
that up and i've been thinking about
some of the people i've really wanted to
talk to before we do that
you've been coming on my show since the
very beginning i mean
28 years uh your first time
was in 93 which is right when we got
started
which blows my mind we have a picture
i was 22. you were 22 there's a picture
of you
isn't that insane appearance
first of all you look fantastic you look
amazing
your face is exactly the same your hair
has changed um
but my teeth look smaller now i think i
had to grow into my face
yeah your teeth are still the same size
but your face got a lot
bigger i see what you're saying i talk i
talked
like i it was i had like an affectation
you know like a comedy
like talk like this oh you did i conan
yeah i'd be like someone asked me for my
number and i gave him a fake
number you know i felt so bad
so i moved there well explain the thing
is
please it's a good joke organically
talked
but you know i think one of the things
that's
really interesting is when you're 22 i
was
30 i think when when you came on the
show because that's
that's how old i had just turned 30 when
we started doing the late night show
and it takes a while to figure out who
you are
yeah comedically and so it's
it's not that you were trying to be
someone else's you're just trying to
figure out how to be you
oh yeah it was i was me then yeah i
thought oh my god look at that
why was i sporting andy look at you why
andy why was i dressed like tom jones in
con what was that
jet or i'm dressed like the riddler or
something no you were probably trying to
seduce sarah that's my
that was yeah that it does look like i
lured you to my apartment
and put up and put on my sexy guy jacket
to try and trick you into liking me
uh i thought it'd be fun uh since you're
here to show some of my favorite
things that you've done on the show over
the years
uh first of all um i want to show this
clip if you don't mind
and i don't want to spoil it so let's
take a look oh yes i came up with a
craft
that you can do with the phone okay
anyone can do it
and uh let's see it would take like
either one of you can do it get
like turn to your head to the side okay
like this like this
and then just let your mouth be loose
and natural and maybe put
but put your lips together and put your
tongue out just a tiny bit
[Music]
well a little more tongue
okay okay
thank you
i really wish you still had the beard
i love your show so much i do
i love it so much the first time i ever
was recognized on the street was
from your show oh is that true yeah
because you'd always have me on and i've
been on your show for so many years i
like grew up on your show i
honestly feel like i
my whole death reel could just be clips
from your show i'd be happy
i say aim higher i say you have a lot of
life left
so rack up more stuff more clips it'll
nudge our clips out of the way you'll
see
well listen i uh i want to make sure i
mention you can listen to the sarah
silverman podcast on itunes and wherever
podcasts are available
click on that click on that yes and
conan needs a friend
[Music]
no i would just mint it i do oh i see
you were mentioning the podcast
i really do need a friend uh we love you
and um you know we're gonna keep
knocking around in comedy so
we'll do other stuff together but thank
you so much for being such a big part of
our foolishness for the last 28 years
and i'm i just i'm just
so happy i love you too there that
stopped that
sarah silverman everybody